good morning everyone good morning and
welcome and happy St Patrick's Day
I am honored Doug and I second gentlemen
are honored to welcome the t-shock and
Mr Barrett to the vice president's
residence you've been here before it is
a great honor of ours as the United
States to know that we have an enduring
relationship not only with Ireland but
with its leaders and so welcome to you
both welcome to you both
uh we are joined today by many
dignitaries including a member of the
cabinet Secretary of the Veterans
Affairs Administration secretary
McDonough and to all of you welcome
welcome welcome
I am excited that we are resuming this
tradition
of recognizing and welcoming Leticia on
the occasion of St Patrick's Day to
date and as you all know Vice President
Biden this was one of his most
particular Joys as vice president and as
you all know he is quite exuberant in
that joy and I now have caught the bug
and our two countries as we know in the
t-shock and I were able to discuss a bit
before we
came in
our two Nations have such a deep
long and enduring history together
and that is through our people and it is
through our traditions and it is through
our common values and priorities as it
relates to International rules and norms
and where we stand in solidarity on so
many issues including most recently the
issue of Ukraine
and what we must do to stand together
joined with our allies
speak out against Russia's unprovoked
aggressions in Ukraine
when I think of the relationship between
our Nations we also and the president
will speak about this later today when
he meets with Leticia
cherish the hard earned and one piece in
Northern Ireland from The Good Friday
agreement and it marks its anniversary
of course this April and it is something
that we take quite seriously and the
president has been quite outspoken about
in terms of our commitment
and as President Biden has said the
Windsor framework is an essential step
to ensure peace and progress and to
ensure that it is strengthened and
preserved
I know that the president will discuss
these matters with you later
and um
as you and I spoke privately again he
takes these issues very seriously
today is also of course a day to
celebrate the long-standing
relationships and the great pride that
we as Americans take in our Irish roots
in the mid 19th century thousands of
Irish immigrants made their way I will
speak now as a point of personal
privilege made their way to California
during the gold rush
and as many of you know most of my
career I spent in San Francisco which
has a long and strong
pride in its Irish roots and um and I
will say that the Irish and the
immigrants who came Generations ago have
shaped the history and the culture of
the United States but I will speak
particular about California and its
impact there
in 1867 many of you may know
more than a decade before New York or
Boston
elected an Irish mayor San Francisco
elected Frank mccoppin of County
Longford yes I am happy to educate
relationships and one of my favorite
stories is of Kate Kennedy originally
from County meath he led the equal pay
for equal work campaign
in 1874 in California
and of course just this week or last
week we here in the United States
celebrated Equal Pay Day
long-standing relationships and
commitment based on common values and
price
and let us fast forward then to 2023
again I will make a California reference
at the Oscars earlier this week
Irish talent was nominated for 14 Awards
and took home two wins and then
yesterday it is my understanding the
Tisha visited my alma mater at Howard
University
to celebrate and strengthen programs
between the students there and the
Smurfette business school in Dublin so
through this and many other exchanges
including the the the pride that both
Ireland and the United States take in
the relationship between Frederick
Douglass
um we show that through the years
through generations the SE this is a
strong and enduring relationship that
makes us all very proud and so with that
happy St Patrick's Day I will now praise
and laugh
toast the Tisha Mr Barris and all of you
on St Patrick's Day happy Saint
Patrick's Day
morning everyone
vice president Harris
distinguish guests and Friends
as we come together at this St Patrick's
Day morning in the raking of bread we
enact what is a most ancient and
enduring expression
of friendship honored across cultures
so thank you very much Madam vice
president for inviting that and me to be
here in your beautiful home and for
continuing that very special tradition
which was initiated by President Biden
when he when he was rested here
as doctors and as proud members of the
LGBT community allow us to say how
inspired we've been by your personal
advocacy for marriage equality
particularly particularly relation to
Proposition 8 and also your defense of
the Affordable Health Care Act
from from Stonewall to Sacramento to San
Francisco America has led the way when
it comes to LGBT equality I don't think
I would be here today were it not for
what America did I know you've been such
a strong Ally for our community
thank you for that
[Applause]
I also want to recognize your role in
defending the Affordable Healthcare Act
in particular and we've a similar
program in Ireland uh plus logic here
we're abolishing Hospital charges
capping the cost of prescription
medicines abolishing doctor fees Dr fees
for children for seniors and for those
of modest incomes and we're phasing out
private practice and public hospitals so
I think those agendas would much in
common
and also much to do
this year as you know we're marking many
anniversaries in Ireland
25 years since the Good Friday agreement
50 years since we joined the European
Union and a hundred years since we
joined the League of Nations
and the international landscape has
changed dramatically in the sweep of
time
for Ireland however one relationship has
endured throughout our close and deep
bond with these United States and we're
always grateful for that
what's the matter vice president today I
want to acknowledge the central role
with the US has played in the peace
process on our Island
driving it Forward at critical points
when few others had the influence to do
so
to mark this um vice president my
delegation and I are presenting you with
an Irish Silver Bell as a token of our
appreciation as an emblem of the
principles that our countries hold dear
Peace and Freedom
of course I'm also conscious of the
special resonance that a bell has here
in the United States with the world
renowned Liberty Bell a symbol of your
freedom and Independence of Hope and
equality principles that will inspire us
for the next 25 years
as we look to the Future the agreement
reached between the EU and the UK you
mentioned earlier in West The Windsor
framework has the potential to restore
very good relations between Ireland and
the UK
to restore relations and the
institutions of the Good Friday
agreement
the old party assembly the power sharing
executive
Northside ministerial Council
it should also help help to open a new
chapter in relations between the EU and
the UK
we're not quite there yet but I think
with good faith on all sides we have
that
help of our continued continue friends
here in America we can get there
my vice president as we work to underpin
piece in Ireland
we cannot be struck
by its apps cannot not be struck by its
absence in other parts of the world
and most especially we think of the
extraordinary brave people of Ukraine
who've endured more than a year of
suffering at the hands of Russian
Invaders
and we stand with them for as long as it
takes
Russia's war is a threat to the
international order on which we all rely
it's an affront to human decency
and we work together to hold
perpetrators to account
and again I want to thank you for the
leadership that the US has shown on this
issue
thank you madam vice president on behalf
of Ireland and all of your for your
leadership on this most important matter
thank you again for the very warm
welcome for your kinds Hospitality here
happy Saint Patrick's Day to you all
thank you